quando sentite la parola microbi a cosa
pensate
la maggior parte delle persone pensa
sporcizia infezioni malattie ma in
realtà i microbi o microrganismi per noi
pericolosi sono solo una piccola
percentuale
la maggior parte di essi ha un ruolo
fondamentale per la vita di ognuno di
noi e per quella dell'intero pianeta
i microbi prendono il loro nome dal
fatto che sono piccolissimi delle
dimensioni del micron il micron è la
millesima parte del mm quindi essi sono
invisibili ad occhio nudo ma compensano
le loro ridotte dimensioni con il numero
infatti sono gli organismi più
abbondanti sulla terra
pensate che un ramo di suono ne contiene
circa un miliardo
essi sono fondamentali per tutti i cicli
biogeochimici per esempio un particolare
tipo di batterio conosciuto come
cianobatterio per primo circa 3 miliardi
e mezzo di anni fa utilizzo di idrogeno
dell'acqua liberando ossigeno inventando
così la fotosintesi e permettendo lo
sviluppo della vita sulla terra così
come la conosciamo noi oggi seppure
inconsapevolmente l'uomo da sempre
utilizzati per la fermentazione di cibi
e bevande e oggi i microbi trovano largo
impiego in diversi settori
dall'industria farmaceutica alla
bonifica di siti inquinati per esempio
vi ricordate il disastro ambientale
successo nel golfo del messico nel 2010
fu il disastro ambientale peggiore nella
storia degli stati uniti circa 9 litri
di greggio al secondo per tre mesi fuori
uscirono dalla piattaforma petrolifera
deep water horizon che vedete alle mie
spalle
la marea nera era impressionante
in tutto furono riversati in mare dai 3
ai 5 milioni di barili di petrolio
ad eccezione di circa 800mila barili che
furono aspirate o dati alle fiamme e
roghi controllati gran parte del
petrolio fu letteralmente digerito da
microrganismi naturalmente presenti
nelle acque dell'oceano e uno di questi
appartiene al genere alcani vorax che
grazie ad un processo chiamato
bioremediation ha quindi contribuito a
bonificare il golfo del messico bene i
batteri microrganismi in generale così
come sono in grado di rimuovere gli
inquinanti da acqua o anche dal suolo
allo stesso modo possono essere utili
per rimuovere sostanze indesiderate da
superfici che noi vogliamo preservare
nel tempo e questo è il caso di un altro
batterie molto interessante di sul fu
vibri vulgaris questo batterio non solo
fatto riduttore cioè utilizza i composti
dello zolfo per respirare così come noi
utilizziamo l'ossigeno grazie a questa
sua capacità metabolica e sul suo vibrio
può essere utilizzato per rimuovere da
statue monumenti le croste nere solfati
che che si formano a causa dello smog
infatti di sul suo vibrio applicato
sull'alterazione è in grado di aggredire
la componente soul fatica della crosta
destrutturando la e permettendo al
restauratore una facile rimozione senza
l'utilizzo di solventi chimici o senza
le sabbiature nel pieno rispetto
dell'opera dell'operatore e
dell'ambiente in questa immagine potete
vedere una statua prima e dopo il
restauro con di tufo vibro vulgaris
ormai è stranota l'importanza che hanno
i microbi che albergano l'intestino
umano e quello di tanti animali di tutti
gli animali ma forse non sapete quanto
siano importanti i microbi che vivono
all'interno delle radici delle piante
un batterio interessante è un
particolare tipo di bacillus che vive
all'interno delle radici di piante
orticole questo batterio stimola lo
sviluppo dell'apparato radicale delle
piante quindi radici più robuste
permettono alla pianta di gestire meglio
la risorsa idrica nel suolo anche in
condizioni di siccità alle mie spalle
potete vedere le radici di una pianta di
peperone trattate con questo bacillus di
fianco invece le radici di una pianta
non trattata queste altre immagini
invece fa riferimento alle parti aeree
delle stesse piante una trattata con
bacillus e l'altra no infine vi vorrei
parlare di alcuni batteri che in assenza
di ossigeno
secondo un processo chiamato digestione
anaerobica sono in grado a partire da
sostanza organica come per esempio gli
scarti dell'agroindustria di produrre
biogas co2 e metano e quindi generare
energia
in questo video vedete un digestore
anaerobico e miniatura che grazie alla
materia organica in esso presenti e
grazie all'attività di microrganismi
riesce a produrre biogas che viene
conservato nel palloncino il metano
presente nel biogas vicino ad un innesco
libera poi energia rappresentato dalla
fiamma bene i battiti però non fanno
solo così utili fanno anche cose belle
per esempio la scritta sulla mia
maglietta isle of microsoft in questa
immagine vede di una fase della
preparazione è stata realizzata con due
batteri un batterio viola isolato
pensate dalla pelle di una salamandra
mentre il cuore rosso è stato realizzato
con un batterio tipico del suolo che i
batteri possano organismi in generale
possono essere utilizzati per dare un
service
all'uomo è un concetto che si sintetizza
in tre parole gestione della risorsa
microbica questo concetto pone le sue
basi su un concetto ancora più famoso
che quello della gestione della risorsa
umana così come nelle aziende il
personale viene gestito guidato in base
alle proprie skills e competenze al fine
di dare un vantaggio all'azienda allo
stesso modo i microrganismi possono
essere gestiti al fine di indurre un
effetto positivo laddove essi vengono
applicati sesso l'acqua il la superficie
di un monumento o all'interno del nostro
corpo
volete sperimentare voi in prima persona
il concetto che appena detto bene se
siete amanti dello yogurt magari è anche
di quelli yogurt probiotici
vi svelo il segreto qualora non lo
sappiate già per avere sempre pronta a
disposizione il vostro probiotico
preferito allora prendete una confezione
del vostro probiotico preferito un litro
di latte una pentola dalla capienza di
un litro col coperchio è una sciarpa di
lana quindi mettete il latte nella
pentola e riscaldate lo alla temperatura
di circa 37 40 gradi
ve ne accorgete che la temperatura
giusta perché emergendo il dito
sentirete il latte un po più caldo della
vostra temperatura corporea
ovviamente lavatevi le mani prima di
fare questa operazione onde evitare che
nel latte si sviluppino prolifica
prolifichino batteri indesiderati
comunque raggiunta la temperatura giusta
versate lo yogurt nel latte mescolate
mettete il coperchio avvolgete il tutto
con la sciarpa di lana e aspettate
un'intera notte i batteri lattici che
erano presenti nello yogurt di partenza
durante la notte si moltiplicheranno e
grazie processi fermentativi tutto il
latte diventerà yogurt mettendo bene da
parte un bicchierino potrete ripetere
questa operazione all'infinito e avere
sempre a disposizione il vostro
probiotico senza poi dover smaltire la
plus
nella confezione è con un risparmio
anche sulla spesa
i batteri che hanno tante cose
stasera ne abbiamo visto solo alcune
come sono in grado di bonificare i siti
inquinati
ap restaurare i monumenti produrre
energia colorare i tessuti fare lo
yogurt far crescere le piante in
condizioni di siccità
quindi la prossima volta che è sentita
la parola microbi
io spero che non vi vengono in mente
solamente pestilenze malattie ma tutte
quelle applicazioni che fanno dei
microbi i nostri migliori alleati nella
ricerca di soluzioni efficaci e
sostenibili ai problemi ambientali
la risorsa microbica è una risorsa
potenzialmente illimitata e se
adeguatamente gestita può essere molto
utile per mitigare gli effetti
dell'impatto antropico sul nostro
pianeta